pour fabriquer du bon compte et il vous
faut du lait et pour produire ce lait il
faut élever une vache comme celle ci par
exemple ou quasiment
et quoi d'autre oui la patache elle pas
blanche dans ce décor en épicéa
le bois utilisé en cave d'affinage 600
m² d'exposition où on découvre toutes
les étapes de fabrication du fromage aop
la nouvelle maison du comté vient
d'ouvrir ses portes
un projet affiné durant dix ans ces
trois bâtiments symbolise les trois
piliers de la filière l'idée c'est de
faire écho à la filière comté avec une
intégration dans le dans le paysage haut
niveau à la fois du bois qui est
omniprésent dans sedan se bâtit et puis
le bardage en zinc qui représente aussi
quelque part le comté sont croûtage sa
patte des prairies à l'assiette de la
ferme à la fruitière ce savoureux voyage
commence naturellement au coeur d'une
salle de traite
bal à la salle de traite il leur donne
des céréales pour les pour les garder en
place
pour l'instant nettoyer le pif c'est
chouette brille c'est marrant parce
qu'on a vraiment l'impression que les
vaches attendent leur tour dans ce musée
ils sont un peu chez eux ces
agriculteurs de quingey font découvrir
la transformation du lait à leur enfant
soit tiré partout vous éclaire canaliser
n'en est très agréable et puis il
découvre quand même plein de choses
qu'on n'a pas forcément sur nous sur
notre exploitation en fait c'est ce que
ça soit ça s'en va faire ça ça me
rappelle mon but lui une expérience
immersive où le visiteur mobilise tous
ses sens
enfin presque pour la dégustation il
faudra attendre la fin des restrictions
sanitaires